bonjour à tous je suis soué le tcttech
aujourd'hui nous allons parler d'un
devoir que tout citoyen doit effectuer
tous les ans déclarer ses impôts tout
d'abord il faut comprendre ce qu'est un
impôt alors qu'est-ce qu'un
impôt l'impôt est un versement d'argent
obligatoire par les citoyens aux
administration publique il sert à
financer les dépenses publiques et
permet le bon fonctionnement de
l'activité économique et qui décide des
impôts c'est le Parlement français
composé de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat qui décide de la création ou de la
modification d'un impôt concrètement à
quoi servent les
impôts les impôts sont utiles au bon
fonctionnement de l'État sans eux on
devrait payer à chaque fois qu'on
utilise un service de l'État plusieurs
milliards d'euros sont collectés chaque
année ils sont destinés aux
collectivités territoriales à
l'éducation à payer la dette de l'État à
la défense à l'enseignement et la
recherche à la justice et à différents
domaines
encore mais qui paye les impôts et
quelles sont les différentes formes
d'impôts tout le monde paye des impôts
je vais vous expliquer comment ça marche
il y a trois types d'impôts quand on
paye une contravention qui est d'un
montant fixe on paye un impôt
forfaitaire quand on achète un bien ou
un service acheter des bonbons ou aller
chez le coiffeur par exemple on paye en
plus du produit la TVA la taxe sur la
valeur ajoutée c'est l'impôt proportionn
en pourcentage du prix enfin concernant
le dernier type d'impôt son taux varie
en fonction de la base imposable plus la
base imposable est importante plus le
taux d'imposition est important c'est le
cas de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est
l'impôt progressif il existe une
multitude d'autres impôts qu'on doit
payer une fois par an comme les taxes
locales qui financent les budgets des
communes de la région ou des
départements par exemple la taxe
d'habitation qui approvisionne la
commune et le département elle participe
notamment au fonctionnement des crèches
et des écoles élémentaires en tant que
propriétaire il y a aussi la taxe
foncière qui sert à l'entretien des
routes et à l'enlèvement des ordures
ménagères il y a aussi la redevance TV
une somme qui sert au financement de
l'audiovisuel public plein d'autres
taxes existent à la Réunion on a
également l'octroi de mare qui finance
en particulier les actions des communes
tout le monde doit payer les mêmes
impôts oui mais tout le monde n'a pas
les mêmes ressources donc l'État a
instauré le principe de l'égalité fiscal
ceux qui touche plus d'argent paient
plus d'impôt sur le revenu et ceux qui
touche moins payent moins c'est pour ça
qu'il est un important de bien remplir
ses déclarations de revenu pour indiquer
combien on gagne durant l'année les
foyers au plus faible revenu ne payent
pas cet impôt mais ils doivent faire
leur déclaration qui leur permet
d'obtenir un avis de non imposition très
utile pour obtenir des aides comme par
exemple les bourses pour les collégiens
j'espère que vous avez bien compris
l'Ance des impôts grâce à un effort
collectif on participe tous au
développement économique de notre pays
maintenant vous pourrez faire votre
déclaration de revenu sans problème à
bientôt pour un nouvel épisode